you know
if you've been watching the news perhaps
you've heard about this the u.s faces a
debt crisis we don't want to default on
our debt this issue has cropped up a
number of times in recent years and uh
so there is such a thing as a debt
ceiling and then congress goes in and
raises the debt ceiling so we can raise
more and more and more debt and we won't
default okay
and and then sometimes the republicans
don't want to raise the debt ceiling so
they had a big fight on this during the
obama years during the tea party years
now there's a question what do you do if
the congress won't raise the debt
ceiling what do you do if the united
states is about to default on its debt
well there is
there is a
seemingly crazy idea that's been around
for some time it's right now it's being
pushed by rashida talib a radical
leftist in the house of representatives
who is saying well we don't even need
congress to to
raise the debt ceiling
the president has the authority to mint
a one trillion dollar coin because of
this one provision of the law that
allows you to mint
a platinum coin of any denomination you
can just mint a trillion dollar coin and
then there you go then you can deal with
the debt and and you don't need to worry
about it and it's a it's a bit of an
accounting gimmick but is this how we're
going to deal with our our spending
problems in this country we're going to
just have the president mint trillion
dollar coins well actually the idea
wasn't just proposed by rashida talib it
was suggested years ago by barack obama
there was this theory that i had the
authority to just issue this uh
through the the mint i could just issue
this massive
a trillion dollar coin trillion dollar
commemorative coin commemorative coin
and then on that basis we could try to
pay off our
u.s treasuries
and
it was a very realistic possibility that
we couldn't get the votes for that and
we couldn't get
those debts rolled over and we would be
in a situation where
technically we're in default and at that
point you were in
uncharted territory
at that point
you were in uncharted territory i guess
that's true and there are some
economists who believe that if you mint
a trillion dollar coin like we're a
failing government of zimbabwe or
something like that that actually the
effect won't be that bad if it's just a
week or so or even if we default if it's
just like a week or so it's not going to
be a big deal we'll deal with the
accounting error forget about it who
cares
regardless of the legality of this
regardless even of the potential
repercussions
this is not how a free people
governs itself this is not how a serious
country deals with its fiscal problems
the way that we're supposed to deal with
that is congress
is supposed to hold the purse strings
remember that's what they taught us in
school has rock i am a bill up on
capitol hill and all that congress has
the purse strings
congress decides how much money to spend
congress decides how much how much debt
it's willing to tolerate
and then the government runs itself and
that way the executive runs the
government according to to that
system
but that's not how it works in our
country anymore
we're now a very frivolous country that
doesn't take any of this stuff seriously
least of all self-government
it is very hard to say that we govern
ourselves in this country if we
have no say over how much money we're
spending
how we're spending that money through
our elected representatives and
if we have
if we don't have a say period because
some
tyrants at google have have seized the
reins of all of our speech in america
and they determine who gets to say what
and who gets to say true things and who
gets to even quote scientific
authorities
and who gets to label that scientific
misinformation i'm so glad that you
enjoyed this video on youtube i'm so
glad youtube let me keep this video up
because sometimes i say true things and
then youtube doesn't want me to say
those true things so they say that the
true things are false things and then
they promote false things and it's
really frustrating if you want to stop
that kind of preposterous dangerous
anti-american censorship i would
strongly recommend you go check out the
audio version of this podcast which is
harder for the big tech tyrants to
censor you can get that at the michael
knowles show it's free apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play wherever
you get your podcasts head on over there
before
some of these other joints try to censor
us entirely
[Music]
[Music]